Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill burn his time for the
Monday morning podcasts from Monday,
May 16th, 2016 how's
it going? How are you?
How's your life? Are you liking your
life? Are you enjoying your life?
Do you hate your life? Would
you like to make a change? Well,
fortunately there's a solution with
my new seven part eight track tapes.
I'll help you turn around your life by
making me a rich motherfucker first thing
you do. Um, anyways, I am
in a great fucking mode.
It's actually a Sunday when I'm
recording this. When I'm recording this.
It's Sunday. And, uh, I got the fucking
shoes.
Yeah.
Juices are flowing.
Blood is flying through my system right
now. Heart grade, fucking wonderful.
You know why?
Cause I worked out the last two fucking
days in a row and my brand new gerage
Raj,
fuck it,
Jay.
Hello. My New fucking
gym. It's finally done.
I went back and I picked
up my, uh, my truck.
You know my old fucking Ford truck that
I had a in storage while they finished
it. They did a phenomenal
fucking job. I, I'll fit it.
The whole thing with a bunch
of rogue fitness shit. And um,
I never fucking show you my house.
I might have to make a video.
I might have to show is a little
fucking chips, a little cute. Cim.
I'll give you a before and after,
you know,
I might even wear my leg warmers for you.
I'll give you a quick two second tour.
The God damn thing. I got my atomic
holds up top and a, I got to tell you,
all freckles,
old freckles lost a lot.
A lot of what little he had. Holy
Shit. I went onto the pegboard.
I felt like,
you know,
the 40 only first time you ever
tried to do a pull up in your life.
It's like this.
It was like you were born without those
muscles because you never use them.
You know what I mean? It's not like you
go, oh, what's on top of the fridge?
You know, what do you do? You
jump up and down, usually cash.
You don't grab the top of it
and fucking pull yourself up.
You little stupid feet squeaking on the
front of the fucking weed as you try to
go up,
which is cheating by the way.
And if you ever made a video of
it and you put it on Youtube,
I'm sure there would be
hundreds of thousands of
comments saying that it was an
epic fail refrigerator. Uh, pull up.
It's cause people like when you fail,
you know why? Because they
don't like themselves. Um,
so it's done. And uh,
I'm so fucking psyched.
Of course there's a few little
doodads we've got to do.
Nia once an elliptical in there,
you know,
which is fucking hilarious to me because
she could give a rats fucking ass about
this gym. And still until it started
coming together and now she loves it,
you know? But what's great is it's the
garage and everybody knows that the woman,
the wife, the fucking, the
fucking lady over there,
everybody knows that they get the house,
but the guy gets the garage and see the
women think that they win because they
got the fucking house. Right.
You don't want the house.
The house is where all
the responsibility is.
The house is where the bills come to the
houses where the fucking people knock
on the door and the cops come. They
go to the fucking house. Nobody,
nobody goes to the garage.
The garage is fucking,
it's, it's genius. You know, you
act like it's a shit hole, blah.
And we'd go up to the garage. They're
like, yeah, yeah. Get out of the house.
They don't give a fuck. You go
into the garage at that said, yeah,
she's getting no fucking
idea. You wait till I, I,
I get one of those little fucking
Kegger raters out there and be doing keg
stands as I do curls.
Right.
Taking in calories as I burn them off at
the same time while getting shit faced.
It's this new exercise video that I'm
going to be putting out, you know,
I dunno what I would call it to get
what you need. Alliteration, right.
Drunk dips or some shit like that.
Right. Just to get people to buy it.
Alcoholic aerobics as too wordy too
now to worry too. Two syllables.
I Dunno what I'll brainstorm on it.
You know,
all you gotta do is just have a fucking
headband on and people will buy the
video. If you promise them you're
going to help him out, right?
You have a fucking headband on,
they spray a little fake sweat
on you and then you know,
all you got to get as a couple of
hotties behind you just smiling and shit,
right? The very least
somebody can jerk off to it,
right? The next thing you know, they
start flying off the fucking shelves.
And then what do you do yet? You add
onto the garage, add on the garage.
I've told you guys forever
my dream fucking house,
my dream house. I don't even
know what the house looks like.
I just know what the garage looks like.
The garage,
don't you say as my dad loved to say
the garage Doe Isi would be a three car
garage, right? One for me,
one for her and the other for whatever.
My old fucking truck. All right.
And then upstairs they all,
there'd be an upstairs.
The upstairs would have a gym.
It have a drum room and a fucking
cigar bar slash fucking sports bar.
That's what it would
be. Okay. One door in,
one door out,
maybe a fucking little ladder to
go up onto the roof to buy you.
Right. And that's, I think
if every fucking guy had
that, there's no fucking way.
You couldn't be a happily married man
because he just could be in the house.
You got your kids running around.
Everybody's freaking the fuck
out and he and I need a break.
I want to be fucking single,
you know, without the whois.
I just want to fucking just sit a
drink without you fucking people in my,
what's left of my hair.
That's where the upstairs comes in.
And then you just go up there.
You have a great time while you
slowly kill yourself, you know?
And then with every cigar you smoke and
every drink you have and you know that
you're one close,
one step closer to death,
which is a great thing because
it's a release, you know?
I don't know. It started off happy. It
got a little dark there towards you.
You wouldn't know that. I'm a happily
married man, uh, by saying all that stuff,
but I also am by nature,
I am a fucking loner. And,
uh, you know, I, I just, you know,
I just need to get away from people
every once in a while and, um,
I'll do that would be the fucking shit.
You know,
I have a couple of cool fucking dogs.
Those dogs at fucking lay around
and like the howl, you know,
like a fucking bloodhound, right.
Just sit there watching the game,
getting hammered, you know, soundproof
walls. You can't hit your family.
He just sitting in there every
once in awhile. You look over your,
your fucking bloodhound.
A rottie roughly what the dog would
bark and join with you. Yeah, I'm, yeah.
You fucking get it. You
fucking get it. Right.
I hope you enjoyed that because
that fantasy though, man,
I, that's it right there.
You know, I don't know what it is.
Some people want the White House,
some people won a fucking Oscar.
And then some people just want,
we'd like to be able to get a Tan and have
a two story fucking garage. That's it.
You know? Um, I'm part of that third
group, part of the third group, everybody.
So anyways, um, I fucking
went down there, um,
used all that rogue fitness shit that
I bought and like I said, you know,
these guys are not paying
me or anything like that.
They actually sent me
those colorful weights.
Now I don't know what the fuck to do
with them cause I have more weight than I
need. So I got some standup
shows coming up in the La area.
If you're building a fucking gym,
you know,
and um, oh, how do I get,
how do I make this a fair contest?
I don't fucking know.
You build in a gym and you listen to
the podcast and you want some colorful
plates, some weights. Uh,
I got them cause I was going to
take it over to play it again.
Sam's have played against sports,
whatever the fuck they are,
but they just so God damn and Celtic,
you know what I mean?
If you think that baldheaded cont on the,
uh,
the pawn shop show how we just fucking,
you go in there and a man,
he got a bar of gold and the guy's like,
yeah,
you know how much you want
for this? You're like, well,
the market value is fucking whatever.
Fucking $1,200 an ounce.
Why don't you give me a, give me a
thousand and outs? And he's like,
so what you really want for it?
But I were on a fucking smash it over.
You've got fuck yourself.
Like what a fucking business people
coming in selling their old fucking hair
dryers. You know their ass out, right?
And you've got to fucking take as much
out of their crack as you can. I get it.
You know what? It's a business. I'm going
to hotter than that guy. God bless him.
God bless them. All right, so play it
again. Sports is the same fucking way.
You'll come in with something with the
price tag still on it and they'll go,
yeah, I'll give you like a dollar 50. You
know what I mean? It's just like, I mean,
they make Richard Rollins
look like a saint.
I mean,
these fucking guys bust you down so bad.
It's like whatever you're selling them.
It's like,
how about I give to you for free,
but I get to hit you over the head
with it first. How about that?
Don't give me any fucking money.
I'm about to just mush it. Right.
And you're fucking,
I'm not doing that.
So I would rather give it to
a podcast listener for free,
but I'm not shipping these fucking things.
Gets like, uh, I don't know what it is.
I think it's two 45
pound plates to 30 fives.
I don't know what it is. That fucking big
and they're heavy. That's all I know. Um,
whenever they're free free
weights. So anyways, um,
I went down there yesterday, I did fucking
chest and Tris. Today I did the, uh,
upper body stuff, all the, uh, bodyweight
shit. Neither wanted the speed bag,
which I thought was a little fucking
stupid. You know what I mean?
I always hated the speed bag unless
you really training for a fight,
you know what I mean? Do to do the,
then you go to your fucking cubicle.
It always seems so,
it just seemed fucking disrespectful
to people actually fight for a fucking
living.
Like the,
the level of respect that I have for
people that do that for a fucking living.
Just the, the, the fucking
courage it takes to do that. Um,
but of course now it's up there and
I'm down there. What did that get?
That pulled the dip abated, but what
it did, data dump, look at that,
that fuck data, that data that then
I'm doing, it popped back up, up, up.
So now of course, now I'm going to
get fucking obsessed with that shit.
I don't know where it's
going to do for me.
I'm hoping it's going to bring my
freckles out, you know? Um, anyway,
speaking of fights, did anybody
watched UFC? You're upstream by day,
not of the red corner. Did anybody see
the UFC one 68, eight, eight, eight?
MMM.
Was basically,
I think the USA or the
world versus Brazil.
And I think Brazil once again
proved that they are raw. You know,
if you want to fucking get into a fight
slash B in the missionary position with
another person, if you think you're
coming out on top of it ain't happening.
They pretty much, they pretty much
dominated the fucking night. But a,
except for this one guy,
and I'm not going to know the
names and actually tweeted the guy,
I'm still not gonna remember his name.
He has a very fucking,
a unique name and it was fucking,
he's fighting this guy and this guy is
making all these silly faces when he's
going and they're going
like the Brazilian dude,
I guess he was a champion or he is a
champion. That's right. He's a champion.
And then he fucking, uh, that
Jesus Christ that was having a few,
when I was watching this,
he fucking, he was fucking,
he was a champion and he was
supposed to fight. He got hurt.
So he wanted to make sure
he's 100% so he's coming down,
he's making all these
silly faces and shit.
And I just remember the announcers
go and like look, and I was like,
no biggest fighter. He's had it
for years and he's making faces.
The camera is not even nervous,
right. All of this shit.
And then he comes to fucking
white dude. He fucking, you
know, old Dudley do, right?
He's got a police officer's haircut.
You like this guy could have been a state
trooper and he's fucking comment down.
And I'm like,
all right,
well let's see what's going to go on
here at the white dude seems to be in a
little better shape.
The Brazilian guy,
surprisingly for a champion as
a little bit of a dad bought,
you know what I mean? And a whatever.
They start going at it and uh,
you know, white boys taking it a little
bit, he's given it bag, he's taking it,
whatever.
Then all of a sudden the Brazilian guy
starts just running at him and he fucking
each one and he get in any regroups.
He starts running man again and
this fucking guy, the white to what?
The fucking state trooper haircut and
he's backing up and as he's backing up,
it gives them just a little
fucking little right there,
Fred with the fucking a
right hook. Right? Well,
backing up and this fucking guy just,
he just shut off this guy's hard drive.
He just fucking pip. And the guy was just
write down like a controlled implosion,
you know,
when they take down a fucking building
and everybody for some reason can take
off work to go down and watch
it, you know, that's what
they wasted a sick day on.
Like, Hey, he's anyway, I can
breathe in that fucking, uh,
what do you call that shit, not asphalt.
Oh Christ, what the fuck do you call?
That shit is best dose, right?
They can breathe it in anyways.
He fucking just hit the guy. I keep just
caught him the right way. I mean, granted,
if he hit me with that,
I mean I would have been dead.
There'd be no podcast ever again, you
know? Um, but he just caught the guy,
I guess. Right. And the guy just
went right, like a ton of bricks.
He fucking went down and the fucking
white dude just lost it. You know,
he just fucking,
who runs over to his corner climbs,
I thought was going to get on the fence.
He went right up and over,
hugged his halting and just kept
screaming, I'm a fucking world champion.
It was awesome. Oh, sorry. Just blow
out years here. It was fucking awesome.
Do I get this too?
I think it's blue on my fucking ears.
It was just fun to see somebody
like dad excited. And uh,
then of course they said
that he was from Cleveland.
So I tweeted out Cleveland finally
want to champion championship and a,
that's why I think that's what I tweeted
out or something like that. But, um,
congratulations to that guy who I can put,
I don't not going to butcher
his fucking name. Um,
it was awesome to see
him win a championship.
It's great for the city of Cleveland.
Right.
And even though it wasn't a team sport,
you know, if you're in Cleveland,
you gotta be, you won't be thinking
this. Cause you guys, you know,
you've been beaten,
you've been beaten down by this sports
gods for so long that you guys really, uh,
you're afraid of having hope.
But I remember reading about Christopher
Columbus when he came over to the,
the the Americas, which he
thought was, I dunno, India.
I don't know what the fuck you
thought. Um, before he got to land,
there was a couple of branches before
he got the land and he started either,
you know,
being nice to people are chopping off
people's hands because they wouldn't give
them their gold fillings. Uh, depending
on what movie you believe, you know,
I always loved that new
studies find, it's like, what,
where the fuck was this information
was it was an on a cocktail napkin and
somebody finally looked at it. Huh?
Did you find one of those scrolls?
Was it written by somebody? Hey, by
the way, this is what really happened.
And somebody just kept it for years and
they just let the light go and go and go
and then fall. Maybe, maybe the
people that that survived what he did,
they had this shit written down. I Dunno,
I think I'm fucking way off track here.
Where the hell am I? Oh yes. So anyways,
he's either way before he
fucking got to land and he,
that was a halfway decent guy or an
absolute fucking war criminal depending on
what you believe. Either way. Don't
you get the day off? You know,
sometimes people got to die to
get a fucking day off. You know,
when you really think
about it. Um, anyways,
the fuck was I talking about? Yeah.
You see some fucking branches and shit.
So there you go.
But guy from Cleveland is a champion.
All right. It starts with once and now
you gotta be looking at the Cavaliers.
I don't think they've lost
yet. You know, it's funny.
Everybody in Cleveland right now is
going shot. All right, I'll shut up.
Just say it. Um, that's
another weird city.
Part of me wants Cleveland to win,
but there's just such a hilarious
misery to the Cleveland Sports Fan.
I almost want to see it keep going.
So I guess I'm going to be happy either
way. I was really surprised at, okay.
See, beat a beat. The Spurs. Um,
considering I never watched,
I just watched the Celtics,
but I was hoping that, um,
I was hoping that, uh, Tim Duncan was
going to get his sixth ring, you know,
just so I'd have yet another thing to
say to fucking Laker fans when they bring
up Koby Bryant. Well, another guy
during kobies time, he was six.
He was a team player.
That one,
he really got everybody involved.
Uh,
did need fucking 90 million free agents
to come in and help him out every
fucking year. All right. Sorry.
Anyway, so let's plow ahead here. Um,
what am I talking about here? So,
yeah, so congratulations. And um,
I was disappointed with the Cyborg fight,
you know what I mean?
I would sit in there going like, yeah,
I know. I want to see this shit fight.
I want to see the, you know,
and you know, I got to tell you,
the women's fights are
usually better than the men's.
I don't know why they go out, like
they go in and like fucking alley cats.
It's crazy. Um, I just don't
understand how they can just hire,
you can just kick somebody in with the
barefoot and it doesn't hurt you too.
You know,
they should fucking have just regular
people like me just go in and do MMA shit
to each other and just watch this both
crumble after the first strike punched
once with your hand. Ha Fuck. You know,
you put in under your, um, anyways,
but she fought some chick. She was
like eight, six, and one. So I'm like,
what the fuck?
She's going to destroy it.
This is going to be over in the first
round. And then Lo and behold, Jesus,
she fucking hits hard.
She fucking was just rain and punches.
And the other woman was, was, you know,
still pool's getting hurt was still way
better than I would have one jab and I
would've been on my back, but she was
fucking eating them for well for a minute.
And then she went down. And then there
was a moment when she was always moving,
but it looked like she was out and
the guy stopped the fight. Right.
Which he shut it. I think it was right
to stop the fight. So in the end,
when they have the official decision,
they cut to her right now and
everybody cheers, gs Brazilian.
It's a hometown crowd.
And when they cut to the other,
the woman who lost sheets like holding
back tears and she's just looking up,
this is why I love this fight. Or forever.
She was just looking up at the fucking,
the diamond vision thing, whatever
the big screen. And she waited, she,
she was on the scoreboard and the
second she was on the scoreboard,
she just goes,
I've never fucking tat tat
and the whole place Buddha.
Okay.
She was so fucking mad.
Um,
which is understandable.
I mean,
I can't imagine train in that
fucking long and that God damn hard.
And then it's just over in like three
minutes. Um, it must have been brutal,
but um, I dunno. She was
great. She was all hard.
So hopefully she'll come
back or what have I done?
I was really into that last one and I,
that Cleveland Guy was hilarious. He was,
he was talking to every, he was like,
you know, and I know everybody here,
you don't like me because we're in Brazil,
but you guys make the sport great.
He called them out on it.
You know,
you're not voting for
me cause I'm a fucking
cause I'm from Cleveland. He should
have been, but I'm from Cleveland.
I'm used to this. Um, anyways,
let's see here. I don't know if
I have any advertising here. Um,
hang on one second. In the meantime,
I'll tell you a quick story.
You guys are all well aware that
the, uh, the genius prince died.
Did you guys see that? Do you get
that and your papers just anyways,
out here in Beverly Hills, they're
having an auction on one of his guitars.
So yellow one that he did.
How many fucking times I got to type
in my fucking password. Come on.
Uh, maybe cause I can't fucking remember
it like that. Fucked it up again.
Third Time's a charm, huh? Hmm.
I have to hum what it is or I fuck it up.
You imagine being this dumb and
actually fucking having your own gym.
It's kind of dangerous,
isn't it? All right. So e
they're actioning off one of his guitars.
It was the one that he used with the,
the new power generation,
the cream album, I believe.
And somebody bought it a few years ago.
I can't believe it was even for sale,
but some guitar collector admittedly
doesn't play him. He just collect some,
he paid 30 grand for this fucking thing.
So he says,
I should read this word for fucking word.
This is so fucking priceless.
And he says like,
the reason why he's selling it is because,
you know, it's become, you know,
with the passing of prince,
it's become so valuable.
Um,
daddy's actually nervous to have it.
He's nervous to own the fucking thing,
right? Which fucking,
it's, it's like, dude,
why don't you just say, you know
what? The Guy fucking just died.
Everybody's paying attention. This is a
great time to sell this fucking guitar.
I'm trying to make money
off of this guy's death. Um,
but can't you just say that? You
know, I hear it. Is Prince's guitar?
All right, I got to read what
this guy said. It's just so, well,
there's nothing wrong with it. You
want to make a buck just, you know,
the guy died and I'm trying to make
fucking money off of it. All right. Um,
but blah, yellow face goes.
I've been a prince fan since
I was a little kid and that
guitar always stuck out
to me because it was super cool and
stylish. Said the current owner,
we paid about 30 grand for it. He said,
unfortunately, as morbid as it is,
when people pass,
their items become more valuable.
I think something is valuable as this
could be too risky to continue to have in
my possession.
He's worried about his safety.
Get the fuck out of him and you try to
make some money trying to make, give me,
you're trying to make some money.
Okay.
That's so fucking creepy.
It's a really cool looking guitar,
but I don't think I could own a guitar of,
of a dead person who was way better
at playing than I'll ever be.
Um, I feel like that should be in like
the rock and roll hall of fame so people
could just go in and look at it.
Stay in your house.
How fucking weird would that be?
Just having people over and people going.
Is that, is it? Yeah,
that's Prince's guitar.
I would immediately be whispering to
my wife going, this guy fucking killed.
Let's get outta here. Fuck.
Does he have his guitar?
It would immediately create me
up, but that's me. You know,
I'm paranoid son of a bitch. He wants
a fucking two story garage. So me,
do I not have any fucking reads this week?
I think I might of advertisers that,
I don't know if you guys have noticed,
but I have slowly but surely
pissed all of them off. Um,
no. Well, well maybe. Maybe I do have
some advertising. He just hasn't sent it.
Nope. I'm hitting the refresh button. I
don't fucking see it now. You know what,
why are they so sense it don't,
they understand that if I shit on it,
you guys actually listen to it and then
maybe you'll buy it as opposed to just
fast forwarding through all of it. That's
what I try to do. I mean, I'm just,
you know, I'm trying to help
them make money right now.
What the fuck are you going to
do? Well, speaking of, you know,
I played for about five,
six years and then I stopped over the
last couple of years when the downstairs
was being redone and then I recently
got back into it. But, you know,
this is the deal. I play drums,
I fuck around and guitar and um,
I've always wanted one of those
lemon burst fucking, uh, Les Pauls.
I'm trying to find one, a lefthanded
one. I just think it's fucking,
I dunno, but you know what kills
me whenever I get to get a guitar,
it was associate Les Paul.
I just start thinking of all
the fucking great music I've,
yeah,
I've heard coming out of that thing and
then when I pick it up, it's just like,
oh Jesus.
Am I the asshole that just bought a
fucking guitar he doesn't deserve.
I think I am.
All right,
I'm going to pause here just
if so I could just fucking,
if I get advertising later, I
could just put it in here. Um, oh,
maybe not. So maybe if dealt, see,
let's see what happens. All right.
Pausing here for some advertising
that might be read later.
All right, I'm back. Did
I read anything? I Dunno.
I guess I'll find out
later. Anyway, so, um,
it's only for 27 here,
Pacific coast time and in 33 minutes,
the blues, San Jose Shacks, fucking, um,
game starts.
And um,
I can't tell you how fucking excited
I am about this and I already know how
they're probably going to sell this game.
That's a tale of two cities,
two cities that I've never
gotten over the hump there.
Fans of add more heartbreak then a fucking
blade blown up fucking spirit through
the chest.
But one thing's for sure for one city,
they'll be moving on to the
Stanley Cup final, not final.
So as I always say, the Stanley Cup
final. And for you, the other team,
more misery. Well, neither
one should be ashamed.
Lave both knocked off between the toile
humble to perennial giants in the west
with the La cakes and they'll
fucking Chicago Black Hawks, right?
They're going to do some shit like that.
Somebody is going to make it to
the Stanley Cup final. I hate that.
It's the final, I like the finals
and I hate when people go, Ooh,
there's only walleyball is all we want,
but there's seven games. So finals. Right.
I'd have no problem with that plural.
That's a great thing.
You know when people go like,
yeah,
all those countries over there
in Europe or around the world go,
why do you call it foot?
Yeah.
You know,
ours makes sense. It's football
and somebody goes, right?
If you want to be technical,
you should call it feet ball.
You use in both your feet. What do
you call it? Football. There you'd go.
You'd trouble right back and forth
between your feet so much called football,
Fidi Ball, footsie, which
called footsie. In other words,
why don't you go fuck
yourself. Um, anyways, uh,
I am really excited about this
and, um, what I would like to do,
don't you see is I would like to have,
uh,
what am I giant ice cubes with some
fucking booze in it cause I booze hard on
the weekends cause I fucking stare at a
God damn script all week before I come
home and booze heart, who's getting
to my drinking is out of control. Um,
I think this is why people have children
at some point in their life because if
you don't,
you just drink yourself to death.
I'll tell you it's fun. It's a lot funnier
than shit diapers. Um, anyways, I am,
uh, I'm nervous about
this one. I'm nervous.
I had a belief that the blues were
going to get by the Black Hawks.
I'm not kidding. I'm
much surprise. And uh,
I had a belief that they could get by the,
uh,
the Dallas Stars and certainly
what the goaltending issues,
which I didn't even know they fucking
ad. Um, there's still went seven.
So I figured this when it makes sense
that you get to the next, each tie,
you get a little blood tested.
So I want to say whoever wins this is
going to fucking win the Stanley Cup in
the Stanley Cup, Stanley Cup final. Um,
but I was hanging out with Bart Nick
last night and he knows more about hockey
than I know about myself.
And he was saying that, uh,
he thinks Tampa Bay lightning know
even though their goaltender went down.
So we shall see. Um, I'm sticking
with the blues. Me. Well,
we low me, meet me at the fair,
I'm sticking with the blues,
that's my team. And um, cause my
real team, the Bruins didn't make it,
but I still love him.
I'm going to be there again in
October and if they play the blues,
I'm not going to give a fuck if they
beat him fucking whatever, 12 to nothing.
I won't give a shit. Um,
speaking of which, somebody
sent me something about, um,
you know,
people always love to make points on
all the dumb shit that I say on Twitter.
Like, I mean, how many times do I have
to admit that I'm a fucking moron?
You really don't need to correct me.
I realize that I'm an idiot,
but somebody goes dictate.
It's not a lot of scoring and soccer
and sends me like one day's worth of
fucking scores. It's just like, okay, well
if you average it out, I think I'm right.
You know, you know what's funny about
that fucking Leicester City Championship?
Do you now they found out that they
won a championship cause to other teams
played to like a one one tie.
There wasn't even a play off play off.
There wasn't even a fucking play
off. Like here we go, this is it.
We're down to the final two fucking teams.
We're going to play for 19
hours and hopefully at some
point somebody's going to
put the fucking ball and then in
the net and the goal, whatever,
and then it's going to be over.
Except it's going to be injury time that
nobody knows what it is except for the
fucking, uh, they'll refs and
everybody starts whistling.
I didn't even have that.
They watched these two other teams play
to with Tai and then everybody went
crazy.
That seems really anticlimactic to me.
I had to think he wants somebody
to fucking kick the ball.
It goes into the fucking somebody scores.
Right.
And then collectively as sports fans, you
all fucking bust your nut. No, Haha. I,
it goes in a bunch of people
walking around and scarves,
watching somebody with win, get a fucking
tie and then you're excited about that.
And I, I don't, I, I
don't get that. You know,
you would think that a country that
survived the fucking blitzkrieg like that
level of excitement in your fucking life,
you think
you'd think use sports would,
would reflect it. Maybe he hadn't.
Maybe you have fucking grandparents
had enough fucking excitement for one
lifetime, annual lifetime too. So they
just started watching that. I don't know.
Well,
maybe I don't understand enough about
the game and I'm just a fucking moron.
Maybe that's what it is. And I don't
know. I have no idea what ever. Go,
go get some fucking fish and chips and
go fuck yourself. All right, let's,
let's read some, um, let's read
some, uh, some of this bullshit here,
but I got from this week, oh, by the way,
I had a great weekend down and before
I get to this, I got an hour to fill,
so don't worry about it. Um,
I had a great weekend and I,
I've just been in a real slump as
far as writing new bits just because,
uh, my life has ground to a
halt here. It's like, you know,
I'm not going out.
I'm not doing anything.
It's like my wife went to the
Beyonce concert last night at, uh,
at the rose bowl and I was
actually thinking I should
have gone because there's
no fucking way. I wouldn't have got a
bit out of that. I would have felt old.
It would've felt stupid.
I wouldn't know what the songs,
when she come out fucking
whipping or weave around and shit.
That'd be something I could
talk about. Right. Um,
but instead I went down to
the comedy store and it did
a couple of shows and, um,
I actually went out,
let's have a comedians that are out there.
And I was just so fucking sick of doing
the same shit and trying to make it
work. I just, every once in a
while, if you just go out there,
yeah.
And, uh, you're just not thinking anything
and he just started fucking talking.
It works way better and it breathes
new life into all your jokes.
I just kind of went out there and,
um,
which is a very terrifying
thing to do when you,
if you've never done that in standup
because you really feel like you're, uh,
you know, do you remember in like
the Matrix when Keanu Reeves,
the trying to convince him to fucking
step off that building and he's not going
to fall to his death, all he has to do
is bully isn't it? Was At that movie,
it was a fucking Battlestar Galactica.
Moonraker I don't know what the
phone in those space movies, right.
It wasn't even space but Scifi.
Okay.
Um, he had to like, believe
it and if you believe it,
then you find if you, if you don't believe
it, you actually fall to your death.
This is sort of one of those things,
but of course you're not going to die.
You just going to,
you know,
metaphorically die on stage
is his basic stepping.
Oh,
off the building is basically just leaving
your act behind and just fucking just
talking.
So I just went out there
and I just started riffing
on fact that I made a smart
move by not going to be
on say, because, you know,
when I went to Lady Gaga with my wife,
mmm.
You know,
I fucking,
I mean she was mad at me for like three
fucking days after that one in defense
of me, which there really, really is
no defense. I watched the Patriots,
we lost I think to the ravens
and the playoffs during the day.
So I was already drinking. I already had
that good six pack in me. And then, uh,
we took a car service to fucking lady
Gaga and we went on the thing and it was,
uh, it's, you know, I'm
all about seeing the band.
I want to see the drummer
and all that type of shit.
And she on this tour for whatever reason,
it's hard towards her choice, whatever.
She had them in.
Like this house,
there was a fucking house and
I couldn't see the drummer.
There was like a window. I could
kind of see his hands a little bit,
a little bit of his head. And that was
it. And it was just like, what the fuck?
I want to see the band. And um, I can't,
it was so long ago. I mean, what the fuck?
But I just started telling that story
and how I fucking pissed her off.
And then if I went to the Beyonce thing,
you know how I would, I would just,
you know,
when they sang like that independent
woman song and everything,
just a dirty looks,
I'd be given most of the women there and
no one that they were full of shit and
that they shouldn't be putting
their hands up in the air. You know,
it was just a smart move that I didn't go.
And my wife still has never gotten over
my behavior at the lady Gaga concert to
the point that I actually asked her to
come on the podcast to talk about the
Beyonce concert. And she just goes, no.
And I tried not to laugh.
I tried to hold it together and I go,
what do you mean though? She goes, we
think I'm a fucking idiot now. She goes,
I'm not going on the podcast and give you,
giving you a,
an opportunity to start trashing beyond
sake. I'm not going to trash Beyonce.
Okay.
I have to admit,
she started showing me
video clips of the concert and she
had it like the way she was holding,
she was, we were on the couch
and she snuggled up next to me.
So she's holding the kind of low
to my, you know, near my stomach.
And like three times I started
laughing, looking at the, uh,
yeah,
looking at the clips. Um, and look, dude,
I know she's way more talented than
I could ever be out and I don't even
remotely put it on a Shiller care,
but it's just something funny to me
about when everybody dances in unison and
they have that, you know,
that angry look on their face.
It's just the funniest assist. Like
what is your, what is the problem
coming up? And they got
their arms out, you know,
and they're doing that little fucking
thing with their head and their feet are
running. Uh, it's just, I can't,
I can't even dance like the
fucking nerve of me to laugh at it.
But it always strikes is just, it's,
it's absolutely ridiculous.
Something, it's,
I understand why it's awesome
and people appreciate it,
but it's also really fucking funny to me.
I should say.
I don't know why. Maybe I get
one, I'm just a cut. Don't
listen to me, so whatever.
So I made a great fucking move
by not going to that concert.
Made a very smart,
married a couple of years getting a
wise in my old, I just was just like,
you know what? I can, that's,
that's the best. When you start,
you start to know somebody and yourself
well enough to be like, you know what?
I see the fight coming. You
know what I mean? It's actually,
it's like slipping punches,
which I, there's something else,
another reason why I
suck at fighting escape.
You could literally tell me on Thursday,
I'm throwing this punch at this time and
you would still not only catch me with
it, you like the feel whole
hand or foot or whatever.
I just can't do it. I, I, you
know, whatever, I stink at it. So,
um, I saw this fight
coming and I was just like,
I was like, all right, no.
And I gave my, you know,
my ticket away and she took
one of her girlfriends.
So I look good with the friends
and all of that fucking shit.
And I avoided a major fucking fight and
I just went on stage cause I was like,
I'm sick of my jokes. That was the point
of this shit. I'm sick of my jokes.
So whenever I get into this, these, um,
whatever you call it, writer's block,
even though I don't write whatever,
just riffing block,
I guess cause I just sort of wing my shit.
Um,
yeah.
I just say to myself, what am I
thinking right now? What am I feeling?
And I was feeling,
thank God I didn't go to Beyonce because
me and my wife would get into a big
fight. So, and you know, it's funny,
I didn't even make that decision.
I kind of as I was don my
rare brought me up. Yeah.
Yeah.
He gives the best fucking intros. He
said, this fucking enjoy goes, you know,
it's next guy coming to the stage.
Uh, you know, he never made me laugh.
You know, immediately people
would just die. They just fucking,
he just does that stuff. But, you
know, people seem to enjoy him. Um,
I dunno. I've written a lot of
his stuff and just, you know,
just making me look
like a complete asshole.
So I went out there and it wasn't
until after I shook his hand that I was
actually thinking of the first bit I was
going to do and I was just like, Oh God,
I can't, I can't, it's physically going
to feel like shit coming out of her mouth.
I can't even say it.
And then I just,
over the years of just knowing that trick,
I was just like,
what am I feeling right now?
It's just I'm feeling,
I'm glad I fucking did go
to Beyonce because I get new
a three day fight with my
wife and I just started
talking about that and it just,
it worked.
And then I had this other
chunk of material and I did
the last joke without even
setting it up from the other shit.
And it's still worth it.
We just worked in a different
way. And um, it was,
it was great. It may be fucking love
standup again cause I was really,
no guy would ever hate standup but just
this whole fucking writing every day.
All right.
Now see the magic of technology is now
10 oh one Pacific coast time.
And I'm watching the third
period of a Saint Louis,
San Jose. Um, I take the fucking game.
Could write a check to go to a,
what's the first two periods?
One St Louis so far. All right. Let's see.
Have you spoken as fucking get on with
the fucking or the sports here. All right.
Uh, you need to know how to cook
when she got a broad your license.
She's old school.
She know what I mean.
Not only do you feel like you
know your way around the kitchen,
but cooking at home,
eating healthier and saving money instead
of ordering expensive takeout all over
again. But where do you start?
Blue Apron as you covered?
Fuck for the last 10 or
less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron delivers all the fresh
ingredients and you need to create a home
cooked meal. Just follow the
easy step by step instruction.
He's me of actually look really good.
Uh,
this was around when I
was a single seller. Uh,
each meal can be prepared
in 40 minutes or less.
No overwhelming trips to the
grocery store, no more sad takeout.
And that a how? Dietary preferences,
no matter your dietary preferences,
Blue Apron,
Nix it,
a bleed and prepared dishes like salmon
with asparagus and new potato Hash and
me Aov right in your own kitchen.
I don't even know what happened.
That is, what's up. Fuck is they only
cook with the ingredients that you've
never used before. Like watermelon,
radishes, Pharaoh, Pharaoh,
modal and purple potatoes and recipes
are between 500 to 700 calories per
portion.
Delicious and good for you right now.
You could get your first
two meal for free. Yes,
we wait for dotcom slash
for that blue apron,
blue apron.com/ [inaudible] a
better way to cook. Oh, here we go.
Me On de Leon d no more sweaty balls
to do me on the and be drinking them.
Maker's mark towards down the fund off
my fucking underwear dries up real quick
and I don't care my ball good bronc in.
So am I by the fucking 10
your queen is all right here.
Whether you're wearing a suit or
whether you're wearing a suit or
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your
underwear unless you Matthew mcconaughey
and then you're wearing that.
She is running down the beach carrying
a couple of hard whenever the fuck it is
he does on TV.
That's a magazine anyway.
But instead of making a
statement like trouper, man,
everyday clothes,
your underwear is probably boring.
The undies is here to change that.
Well you don't see what it has on the
is pretty boring as it is. Just read.
You saw, you know this fucking name on
it. That's when it gets interesting. Um,
please include all the volume. Why
would not eroded? I'm going to read it.
Modal is pronounced modal.
Every pair of me undies is made from
sustainable mode out fabric twice as soft
as cotton, allegedly nothing can describe
the fit and the feel of me undies.
He got to feel it up against you,
evolved to appreciate it.
But once you fire him on your understand
why they're called the world's most
comfortable underwear. And if you know,
when you first fairly on the east,
no questions asked me and he says dozens
of styles and limited edition prints
to,
if you make a statement
with your underwear where
there anyone can see them or
not. Remember Superman. Um, uh,
they're really great marketing them.
Spoke towards the comicon crowd.
I think it give a fuck about superman.
Didn't he lose the Batman?
A shipping is free and you went
and Canada, you can save up to $8.
Prepare with me on these subscription
plan and get the subscription or a single
pair.
Get points is done off your first order
when you go to [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot coms
Rashford for 20% off your first order.
And then here we go. The
final one, legal zone,
five things you can count on when
using legal zoom for your business.
Number one, more than a million people
have already trusted legal zoom to stop.
Start that business and
corporations, LLC, nonprofits, Dva,
whatever the fuck those are and more use
legal zoom to get started the right way.
Uh,
number two,
the deuce experience you can put on
needles zone for all that you can count on
Eagle Hill for all the
details they helped,
they've been helping all types of
businesses, owners for over 15 years.
Number to numeral chase,
helpful support.
They have the right people standing by
ready to help you with your questions all
based in the United States.
Ooh, shot fired India,
a number of
legal advice.
Legal isn't a lot fun.
So they built a network of independent
attorneys available in 48 states.
You get answers to your legal questions
and they can reduce supplier concepts,
employment laws and help with most of
the day to day situations that pop up.
And finally, letter D A, g, c,
d, that's the first one. Single, uh,
well adults.
I learned how to count to 10 in Spanish,
wasn't about Boston
get knocked down. They always go like,
you're going to get the fuck up or what?
Call the actual make smart choice for
your business and legal zoom.com today.
And don't forget to
enter@checkouttosaveevenmorelegalzoom.com.
All right, that's it. Back to the
park chest. You sons of bitches.
Let's get to some questions
here for this week.
Oh,
um,
speaking of which, how great his song,
his top Jimmy. I fucking love that song.
All right, so I Annika. Hey
Bill, love your podcast.
I want him to tell you about my
sister's cure for s a Sayada ACOG lie,
but don't worst. Okay. Cloud. Um,
the providence center chat
and I one night only shy
my ass fucking
um,
she suffered from Sciatica for years.
For years.
Her doctor recommended
she see a podiatrist.
That's a foot doctor for all you civilians
out there who filmed her from behind
fucking creep as she walked
on a treadmill. Yeah.
What are these yoga pants,
by the way?
I don't understand why guys are
fucking so obsessed with yoga pants.
I've never been yoga pants.
I like just, you know what?
I took too many yoga classes.
I just know what the room smells like and
I just feel like that's what you clamp
smells like when you wear those. And
I know that's immature. I'm sorry. Um,
he immediately saw her right foot
was rolling out. Is she walked,
he said this was causing
her problems with Sciatica,
and he made custom orthotics shoes,
inserts that she wears most of the time.
She said this worked immediately to
completely eliminate her pain from Sadeka.
Ooh. She said, after you
start wearing the orthotics,
you should visit a chiropractor to get
everything back in alignment and you're
good to go. Give it a try and go fuck
yourself. Thank you so much for that. Um,
I don't think I have that issue,
but I got the name of a good chiropractor
and you know what, God dammit,
when I'm uploading this podcast,
I'm actually going to go see
a doctor because somebody
sent me this thing on, um,
on Twitter. Go Bill, go see a doctor.
Jesus did we learn nothing from so and so.
And it was somebody who
was on Letterman who was,
she had a shortness of breath
and he kept blowing it off.
He kept talking to people who
weren't doctors and they're like,
I'm sure you're fine.
I'm sure you find.
Then he found out it
was fucking lung cancer.
Obviously that's not what I'm
looking at here. Um, all right.
Uh, so I will definitely go. Oh, thank
you for that. All right. Number two,
uh,
Duke
where we'll Katelyn take his shit
this week. Um, number two. Hi Bill.
I was a wall and floor Tyler for 27 years
and my go to for any lower back pain
was a gel ice pack in
lying on a hard floor.
The Gel pack molds to the area that is
sore and the hard floor keeps you spine
flat. Lie on your back. Wait,
lie on your back on the
floor with your knees bent.
Put the ice. No, what does that mean?
They bend and then lift them up or
just to have the feet on the floor. Um,
can you put your foot down on the
two? Get jump up on the one. Sorry.
Thinking about prince now. All right. Um,
then we'll the ice pack and then try it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I missed the
whole fucking thing. It lie on your back,
right?
You know what it is? He wrote a bunch
of words that are all like the same.
I have some sort of fucking dyslexia
because he has lie like a bunch of times
and feet lie on your back on
the floor with your knees bent.
Put the ice pack at the spot, giving
you trouble. Leave it there. Oh,
I know why he didn't have any punctuation.
Leave it there for 15 minutes.
You can watch TV doing this then moves
the ice pack and then try to feel like
you are pressing your
spine into the floor.
Continue with the treatment once or
twice a day until you feel better.
I hope this works for you.
I loved F is for family and reminded me
of my childhood and I'm a 57 year old
Australian male. Love the specials and
the podcast. Hope you get better soon.
Well that's good to know.
So you're 10 years older than me.
Well that should work because we kind of
age bill a little bit older than I than
I was in 1973 or 74 he's about 11 years
old and which would mean he would have
been, would have been born in 62
so that's right in your wheelhouse,
right? You probably be
born and like what, 58 59.
Yeah. Built. That's how the math
works out. All right, cool. Um, okay.
Australia mailable for thank you so
much for watching and please tell more
people down there in Australia
if you can to check it out. Um,
I actually heard a lot of times people
say to put heat on your back ice I guess
is better. Uh, cause it, if
you have any sort of, uh,
inflammation in the nerve or
something like that. I Dunno.
I've been using a leaf
and doing these stretches,
I feel much better and I haven't
been sitting down at all.
I've actually been squatting like
a Vietnamese gambler and, um,
I don't know. I, uh, that's been
working for me in these stretches.
I still haven't quite gotten it
better, but I'm going to walk,
go to a chiropractor and get adjusted
out Jesus. And you know what? I that,
and I also need glasses finally
giving into that because my, um,
every two years when you're at my advanced
age, you got to go get a physical,
physical.
I want to get physical.
Um, I got my pilot's license.
So you got to every, you know,
if you're a younger fella, every floor
lady lady, every five years you, you,
you got to renew your medical, um,
you gotta get it updated. So with me,
it's every two fucking years and I
barely made it through and I'm literally
like, what the fuck am I doing here? I
don't want to wear glasses, just don't,
I just don't want to have another
fucking thing that I have to deal with.
And I also have this paranoia that all
glasses do is make you fucking eyes
worse. Kind of like a chap stick. It
just dries out your lips even more.
That's like the big urban myth.
And then you get addicted to it,
then he got to use it. You know,
whenever I have dry ass lips,
I just use a little Vaseline works like
a fucking charm and then I just started
pounding waters and then you're fine.
You fucking fine that fucking
chapstick and all that shit.
I don't like it and don't like it
makes me have weird dreams, you know,
get that chemical in there and seeps right
in the fucking face and it goes right
to your brain.
And next thing you know,
you're just running around
with an ax and your drinks.
You have to have a dream like that.
So raise a year screaming, answer me.
Uh,
I'm just making this shit up.
People out. I don't know what the
fuck you want from me. Usually the,
the advertising takes up a
little bit of time and I,
and I don't have any full 48 another
12 minutes and then the game stats.
Oh, and I got another 15 minutes here.
Fuck. Well thank you. Thank God for Tivo.
Right? All right. Grass
killin name. Alright,
a fantasy revenge advice.
Hello billion.
I'm a 23 year old male.
I live with my parents in the
country that even Australia makes.
Oh Wow. They, even Australia makes fun
of two from a Australians here. Oh,
New Zealand.
Oh Jesus.
I live with my parents in a country that
even Australia make fun of New Zealand.
I thought he meant a part of a country.
I can't read people.
I love emphasis for family and can't
wait for season two. Thank you so much.
Please tell more people in New Zealand
about it if you haven't already.
If he got the time.
I'm not trying to put you out if
you don't want to be that Douche,
don't be the Douche, but if
you do, I'd, I'd appreciate
it. All right, so here we go.
Fantasy, revenge advice. Sometime ago,
my father was using a lawn trimmer
on the right side of the front yard,
which is only a few feet
from our neighbor's driveway
while trimming the edges
of small rock in the grass shutout and
hit our neighbors parked car in the
driveway.
Our neighbor was already at the front
of his house and either saw or heard the
bang and started yelling at my
dad who was apologetic. The Rock,
the rock put a small dent in the car,
which was hard to see even close up
when I, when I was told what happened,
my dad by my dad,
I was a little pissed that he yelled,
but I knew he had a right to be upset.
And although it was an accident,
my dad would happily pay for the
damages because he knew he was at fault.
Um, our neighbor didn't talk to
us again about a bill or anything,
so we've quickly forgot about it
and moved on. A few weeks later,
I was at the front of our house and I
saw that the right side of our lawn was
completely dead of foot inwards.
I realized this fucking cunt had
poisoned the area of the grass that would
usually be cut using the trimmer.
Wow.
This guy's got major communication issues.
So this incident would never
happen again to state my,
despite my dad telling him that he would
only mold alon when the driveway was
empty in the future.
Um,
I asked my dad if he knew anything and
he told me he had known for a few days
but didn't want to make
a big deal about it.
My Dad is a very easy going guy who
doesn't get bothered much myself on the
other hand, spent the night, uh,
the next few nights
fantasizing about revenge. Oh,
it looks like you take after your
Ma. All right. Get Dad's easy going.
He married a fucking hot blooded woman
and she's, you know, she calmed her down,
right? And then you, you, you, you got
her fucking DNA. All right. I like,
I like where this is going so far,
even though I'm not a big revenge guy.
You Dad's easygoing. It's
his house already. My Gut
saying your dad's easy going.
It's his fucking house, you know? Um,
yeah,
don't do anything to disrupt it.
And you said it.
I thought about doing the
exact same thing to his lawn,
but spelling out the word coward.
Oh my God. That's fucking hilarious.
I thought about pulling out all of his
plants and dumping it on his car to send
a message.
It's been a few months and I still
get pissed off when I think about it,
but I decided not to stoop to his level
and pull off a bitch move like that.
The only option would be to confront him,
but there is no scenario in which
that would end. Well, why not?
Um, why not? Why can't you just next
time you see him just say like, dude,
I got to tell you something. I haven't
been on this planet for a long time,
so maybe I need to see
more bitchy behavior,
but that's the biggest pussy bitch
fucking way. I don't do that.
It's going to cook. I don't
know. I would just say, hey,
you have any idea why this part of
the lawn died? Isn't that amazing?
And I would do that to
them every fucking time.
Just do something to drive
him nuts. Anyways, he goes,
I've decided to do nothing and moving on,
but it's been about a year and
I'm still thinking about it.
What would you have done?
Am I justified to be pissed?
This pissed and how the fuck do I stop
myself from letting it get me in such a
bad mood every time I walked past our
front lawn and see the dead strip of
launch. Thanks for listening,
Bill. Come back to New Zealand. Um,
your lawn is still dead.
Look,
I'm not big on revenge,
but the great thing that you have
right now is you've waited a year.
Um Hm.
So if you were to do anything,
obviously don't bring any
physical harm to the person. Um,
he does seem to love that car.
It's just why would you do it?
MMM.
Why don't you guys read,
just replant the fucking grass.
That's what I would do. I would
replant the grass. This is what you do.
Replant the grass
and get all excited.
And then without him knowing what you
do is you set up a fucking video camera.
All right? And he just videotape and
you, you try to catch them doing it.
That's the best way to do it.
Right?
And then he has to fucking pay for it
and then pay for the previous thing.
The previous time he poisoned
it. Like, that's what I would do.
You know what I mean?
There's obvious things that you could do.
You could go to a fucking auto zone and
buy one of those little catch trays that
captures oil, you know? And then when
the night you could undo his fucking
let all the oil out of his car on screwed
the thing on the oil pan and you screw
it back up and then he seizes the edge
on his car. You can go that route,
you know, there's no oil
in the fucking car. Um,
the key is what you have to do is
okay,
he would still figure it out.
So you can,
you can't do this is all bitchy
fucking moves. You know what I mean?
You got to have a face to face thing.
Or what I would do is I
would just repaint three,
plant the grass and I would
set up a fucking video camera
and maybe just say that. Just
say, hey, just so you know,
if you plan on poison Eric Grass,
cause I know you're not a man and you
would never say anything to my dad's on my
self's face. You know, just so
you know, I got this security,
you're going to be on video and we're
going to catch you doing it. Okay?
All right? It costs us a lot of money
and I, I, oh my God, what a, uh,
in a perfect world, could you just
go over and just fucking take,
just answers the door and you go hi.
And he is Buddha right in the nuts. Huh?
You would think they need just take a
strip of the dead grass and you just start
fucking beating his back with it.
That's what the fuck you wanted. Do I?
You know what? I actually want to do
that right now. But you know what?
You can't do it. You know what?
Fuck him. He did it to you.
He did it to you.
Oh Dude. You know
something? I think you're,
I think what you came
up with this the best.
Why don't you just write coward?
No.
Cause then he's going to do
something else to your dad's house.
Oh, this guy's a cunt. You know what?
He doesn't have the balls to confront
your dad. So when I think you'd do yet,
do the little cow thing and then set
up video cameras and catch them doing
something else, but then you've done
something to him. See, it's just,
it's just awful. It's just as
bitchy tit for fucking tat thing.
I don't know what you have to do,
but I feel like something has to be said.
At least
I know what you do.
This is what you do.
You go down to a fucking lady shoe store,
all right?
And you buy a cheap pair
of fucking women's shoes
and next time you see you wrap it up
like a present and you just give it tool
and there's a card in there and
everything. And then you just,
this is what you do.
You do that.
You just humiliate the guy and he just
open it up and just say, hey sweetheart,
just want to get you,
you,
you just write from your heart
about what a fucking bitchy is.
It just is what you do. Don't ever,
don't curse in it at all. Right?
It really nice and
lovely. Um, but in that,
without ever cursing,
just let them know what an absolute
fucking pussy he has for doing that bay.
You Go, oh, that's, I, I think that,
you know what? I think that's a winner.
You know what? I might have to, I might
have to outsource this to my listeners.
If you guys have better ideas of
what to do there. Nobody gets hurt.
You made your point. It's fucking
hilarious. And that's a funny, you know,
you tell people that this guy did it and
they go, so what'd you do? He tell him,
I went out, I went to a lady's Tish, she
was doing, I bought him a pair of pumps.
Okay.
And then you get to laugh and every time
you see him just wave and just start
calling them sweetheart Kim,
a pet name.
Maybe you give him a woman's name like
Diane or something. Just, hey, Diane,
how'd you like the shoes?
And just every fucking day,
you can just do that forever.
I Dunno.
It made me feel better about the
situation. Maybe you can do that.
Who the fuck knows? Anyways,
good luck with that. Uh,
but don't do any physical harm or
real property. That's the brilliance.
I must said genius. Pat Myself on the
back there. Sorry about that. Um, that's,
that's what I like about the last
plant is that you're not hurting him.
You write it eloquently. You're not
cursing. There's nothing he can really do.
You just bought him a gift that you'd
give. You'd give a woman, it's perfect.
You know,
I'd send them to the candy on Valentine's
Day. Just, Ah, just torture the guy.
But you just keep giving them gifts,
you know,
I don't know what else, what's
some, get them some flats.
Okay.
I Dunno. Just a bunch of shit like
that. I don't know who the fuck knows.
Maybe you just do it
once and then that's it.
And then what you do and then right
after that you replant the grass and then
you just let them know that you know,
that he did it and he's going to be too
much of a bitch to try to do it again.
And then he can tell you dad years later
that that's don't tell your dad that
you did it.
And then years later,
you're telling me you did it when you're
having a pint and you guys can fucking
laugh your balls off. All right.
Work argument. Um, hey bill,
I work with some real morons.
I'm in sales,
so everyone is a hotheaded tool. Really.
I thought you guys were like funny.
It always seemed like the salesmen were
always breaking balls and being funny.
Um, they all think they're living
in a sales movie. Oh, okay.
Too many Glengarry Glen
Ross. All right. Uh,
we have set accounts and nothing about
our job requires us to generate new
business from cold leads,
but that doesn't stop these tools.
So the other day they're bitching about
Saturday night live and how it's not
funny anymore.
That's not really a big deal.
People always bitch about SNL even
when it's good. That didn't bother me,
but then they all started saying
how they'd be funnier on the shell.
No, Jesus. Here we go. This is like maybe
watch. No, I guess it's not like that.
All right, let's continue. I'll just say
it's like me watching UFC being like, oh,
you know what I wanted done.
Um,
so this is when I chimed in and told
them that it's harder than it looks and
that they did not. They did
not. They did have a shot. What?
And that they did have
a shot. Oh, the, oh,
that if she left out a word there said
it's harder than it looks. And if they,
if they did have a shot at having no
stage presence or Rick or experience,
they would end up freezing up,
then they'd be the guy who froze
up whose face was everywhere.
I made the point to them that if
they were offered a spot on SNL,
they'd be better to turn it down.
They'd have a happier life if
they said no to SNL. Jesus,
do you agree with this? And if you are
offered SNL, would you take it? Um,
okay.
Two, I think that the people on SNL are
funnier than a salesman. Yes, absolutely.
Absolutely. Do I think that they
would freeze up now? Not necessarily.
They would probably, you know,
maybe a few would freeze up.
Others would get dry mouth and still
plow through it. Others would ham it up,
you know, who knows. Um,
yeah,
I dunno.
Um,
yeah,
their eye,
if they offered me SNL,
I would know that they
were in a lot of trouble.
I am a 48 year old man next month.
I think that they like to try
to get young talent and um,
I think that window has closed.
Um, I haven't said that.
I got nothing but respect.
It seems like haven't just trying to
write a fucking cartoon where we got all
the fucking time when the world to do
this shit where they have to come out with
a brand new, you know, 90 minutes
minus fucking commercials.
Um,
what's that 90 minus 24 to get
technical eight minutes every half hour,
that's 64 fucking 66 minutes a week.
Fuck you.
There's no way I've or I've heard nothing.
But that's an absolute,
it takes a special personality to be
able to do that well, to handle that.
And um,
I would actually be worried about
what it would do to my standup career,
having that level of a commitment.
Um,
which is why I prefer to do a role in
a movie where it's just sort of like,
okay, we got you from here to here.
So it's a finite thing with at SNL.
Shit is just like, I don't know when
they started, when they stopped,
but it just seems to be a, it's
a hell of a commitment. But, um,
yeah, so they go, did I
answer your question? Um,
yeah.
I'll have to get offered SNL. Who
says fucking note of that? Um,
I dunno. I Dunno if I get that on.
Why am I fucking stressing over this?
It's not happening.
But anyways,
thank you for sticking up for everybody on
SNL. I appreciate that. All right. Okay.
Here's the last one from a
lady from a fucking lady,
a woman proposing Yo baby cakes.
Belieber uh, just curious.
What are your thoughts?
What are your, what? Oh,
just curious what your thoughts are.
Sorry everybody. I'm bad at this.
Just curious what your thoughts
are on women proposing love you.
Thanks for advocating for pitfalls.
Hope to see you soon.
Please don't use my name while
they never show me your name. MMM,
I think that's a bad
move on the woman's part.
Uh,
I think you guys generally speaking,
are more gung Ho to get
married than guys are.
And um,
if you propose to a guy and he's
too much of a pussy to say no.
Okay.
Um, and then you ended up
marrying the wrong person.
I think as a woman you should
wait for the fucking guidance.
I think there's a reason why the guy asks.
Yeah.
Um,
it's because we don't want to do it.
So if we are actually asking, then
you know, you with the na, that one,
most of them ended up in divorce.
You know what? I don't know. MMM.
I don't know. That could be
maybe be kind of cool. Okay.
There's something cute about it. I can
tell you that. Not talking down to you,
but uh,
I used to always fake proposed to Nia.
Now he's, so he's go Nia, I'm
proposing to you right now.
And she would always be laughing,
knowing I was fucking around and I would
always go, I propose that we break up.
It was a silly joke and he used to
always make her fucking laugh. Um,
I dunno.
She was real cute during that time
when she like wanted me to ask and uh,
I dunno. My wife's fucking adorable.
So I mean, what am I going to do? MMM.
Took a special kind of fuck a
woman to trick me into doing this.
Uh, she didn't trick me. Anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
I don't know if I have any advertising
left anymore, but who gives a fuck?
I never did it for that anyways.
Right.
I'll go out and go dance
for my supper tonight.
You're advertising the water money,
although I loved it. Oh, I love that.
Advertising horror money. Maybe
I still have it. Who knows.
That's the podcast. Once again, um,
I will try to take some video, uh,
this week I actually
made a couple of ones,
but I made one for visy and I
made one for fucking Dean del Rey,
so it's got their name on it.
Um,
when I say maybe I'll just
post those fucking things.
I don't have to fucking move my truck
out again. Do I? Anyways, that's it.
That's a podcast for this week.
Thanks for listening.
Go fuck yourselves and
I'll check on a Thursday.
Let's go blues.